un trasplante esperanzador un equipo de
cirujanos del lenguaje langón health en
la ciudad de nueva york unió con éxito
un riñón de cerdo a un cuerpo humano se
trata de un logro que podría contribuir
a la falta de órganos humanos para
trasplante
es básicamente lo que hicimos fue
trasplantar un riñón de cerdo modificado
genéticamente que tenía eliminada la
molécula principal que define la
incompatibilidad de un órgano entre un
cerdo y un humano
en la que los genes del riñón habían
sido alterados para que sus tejidos ya
no contuvieran una molécula conocida por
desencadenar un rechazo inmediato en el
cuerpo de los seres humanos por lo que
el órgano pudo funcionar de manera
adecuada durante 54 horas por fuera del
cuerpo de una paciente con muerte
cerebral con el objetivo de poder
monitorear lo durante las 54 horas en
las que llevamos a cabo el estudio el
riñón funcionó perfectamente de la
manera en que debería funcionar
el riñón de un donante vivo-- el
procedimiento es visto por parte de la
comunidad científica como un paso clave
para hacer realidad los llenos
transplantes o los transplantes de
animal a un humano creo que prepara el
escenario para que se hagan nuevos
trabajos en los próximos años pero
verdaderamente nos dice que estamos en
el camino correcto y que ya sabes el
éxito está en el futuro cercano y no en
un asunto de décadas como en el pasado
el hallazgo todavía debe superar otras
pruebas para ser aprobado por la
administración de medicamentos y
alimentos de eeuu al igual que varios
cuestionamientos éticos sin embargo es
una luz de esperanza para las cerca de
90 mil personas que solo en eeuu están a
la espera de un riñón de las que 12
personas mueren a diario esperándolo